(bright music)
There's no place like home.
And for chef Nik Fields, that's Phoenix, Arizona.
Where one of her passions is highlighting local business.
Ours is too Nik!
And watch this very special hometown tour.
Hi Drew it's chef Nik.
I'm here at Arizona's family studios in Phoenix, Arizona.
One of the things I love about my hometown of Phoenix, is it
has 365 days of sunshine.
Come on, let me show you.
Welcome to Tempe beach park.
You have people that are riding their bikes, people walking,
skateboarding, paddle boarding.
At night time there's concerts.
it's a really happening spot.
We're here at the beautiful Desert Botanical Garden.
I love this place because I used to take my daughter here
when she was little.
They have the most beautiful butterflies, and they have over
50,000 types of plants.
We are here with Dana, the director of marketing.
Dana, can you tell us a little bit
about what makes this place so special?
The garden is just such an icon in the valley.
We're filled with all these beautiful desert plants from
around the world.
Plus we have the most beautiful exhibitions and events
throughout the year.
It's just a great place to immerse yourself in nature and
explore the desert.
I'm here at Mary Coyle's ice cream shop,
the oldest ice cream parlor in the state.
But also home of my favorite dessert, the root beer float.
Oh my God, It's so yummy.
Howard, what makes Mary Coyle's so special?
Why should people visit here?
Well, for one thing,
we've been serving up smiles one scoop at a time for 70
years.
And now we're here at chic chef marketplace.
I create every single product that is on the shelf.
Not only is it created by me,
it's created with love.
This is just a beautiful snapshot of this
beautiful town of Phoenix.
I can't wait for you to come and visit yourself.
See you soon.
Wow Nik, I'm bursting with hometown spirit
and that's not even my hometown.
Although I do love Phoenix, Arizona.
The last time I was there, I went to Taliesin west,
the Frank Lloyd Wright house. I can't wait to come back.
Thanks for showing us around.
(upbeat music)